el monto de las reparaciones reclamadas
por la república democrática del congo
uganda ante la corte internacional de
justicia corresponde a la evaluación de
los daños hacia los bienes y las
personas durante la segunda guerra del
congo entre 1998 y 2003 kinshasa afirma
que 400.000 civiles perdieron la vida
como consecuencia de la ocupación y que
600.000 personas han sido desplazadas
también se incluyen en esta cantidad las
reparaciones por daños a la propiedad
incluyendo el saqueo de los recursos la
explotación de los bosques y la
destrucción de los parques naturales
en 2005 la corte internacional de
justicia órgano judicial de la onu
encargado de resolver los edificios
entre estados dictaminó que uganda debía
pagar una indemnización a la república
democrática del congo entonces los dos
países tuvieron que negociar el monto de
la factura
desde el inicio del procedimiento uganda
refuta la cantidad calculada por
kinshasa argumentando que uganda no era
el único país involucrado en la guerra y
que la factura es demasiado altas la
falta de conciliación entre los dos
países hizo que el proceso se alargará
las cosas se extendieron hasta que en
2021 las dos partes presentaron por fin
sus reclamaciones al tribunal para que
el arbitraje sea definitivo